president biden celebrating earth day by
promising he'll force
america to do its part to save the
planet
the united states sets out on the road
to cut
a greenhouse gases in half in half by
the end of this decade
this is a moral imperative an economic
imperative
a moment of peril but also a moment of
extraordinary possibilities
and private jet loving john kerry says
all the co2 from the atmosphere
needs to go even if we get to net zero
we still have to get carbon dioxide out
of the atmosphere
so this is a bigger challenge than a lot
of people have
sort of really grabbed onto yet
talk about sucking out the atmosphere
jesus dagin
my favorite part about this whole thing
is that they make these goals
of reducing emissions but the planet's
supposed to be
over by then didn't we only have eight
years left
so what's the point right well they're
gonna
we won't control and uh they want to
destroy
lives and livelihoods certainly in the
united states
despite the fact our emissions have been
falling dramatically
and they they want to destroy lives and
likelihoods and
do it by government fiat this is not
through innovation
this is not through uh
creation of new technology it's
literally joe biden is just counting on
not being around by the time
uh everybody is unemployed in this
country we are handing our economic
power
to china and other nations that hate us
a
belch out of john kerry or joe biden
would be more honest
than what we've heard it would smell
like wood you know martha
one way to reduce the emissions is just
to keep us locked down
you know how interesting is that except
john kerry because he's very important
and he can't get to his meetings
unless he has the private jet but you
all understand um
what i think is fascinating here is is
china right so china watches this and
they're trying to compete with us
militarily economically in every way
possible
so they say they chimed in and one of
the deputies uh
in the chinese government said you know
we have 1.5 billion people here
i just don't think it's realistic for us
to try to do this
and i thought well that that's that you
know i mean
they're not even going to attempt this
they said we're going to keep going up
up up in our emissions until 2030
and then we're going to max out we're
going to peak in 2030 and then after
that
we'll come back and we'll chat with you
about maybe cutting back so i mean it's
just
they love it it's great for their
economy and they're just going to watch
us close all these industries
and they just it works perfectly for
them yeah juan i
you know i'm really hopeful that chyna
will take inspiration from
us and close all those coal plants that
they're building right now
because i think they're going to see the
magic of joe biden's ideas in the green
new deal
what do you think well there's no
way that we can enforce it but that's
the idea
and that's what you just heard from xi
jinping today he said they were going to
have strict limits on use of
coal in china i mean you know he might
sell you a bridge or something but let's
see what happens but
we got to try to get people on board and
today it was inspiring to see that you
had not only
the chinese leader you had the russian
leader but you know the argument here at
home and the one i'm hearing from
you guys today is is puzzling to me
because
you know a lot of the big unions
including a lot that you know represent
a lot of trump voters
but they're on board with president
biden's plan
i mean you think about it uh the
international brotherhood of electrical
workers the uaw the whole auto industry
you think about seiu the big union
they're all backing
the biden plan you think about wall
street record highs
setting records why they like this plan
i think the stock market went down today
i don't know why the union
i don't i don't know why the unions
would back this what could the reason
for that be
jesse well what does juan always say
jesse
the gm they say they want to go green
don't you think that's a good thing and
i say juan they're virtue signaling for
federal contracts and guess what i found
tucked away in biden's two trillion
dollar infrastructure thing
174 billion with a b
dollars for electric car production you
think gm is going to get a little bit of
that
so joe biden takes all of our tax
dollars from the workers
and gives it to a large corporation who
then puts up no money
gets all the profit from an electrical
vehicle line that they've just moved to
mexico
and then they all get to congratulate
themselves for going green
that's called crony capitalism it's
called corporate welfare
and it doesn't do anything for the
environment because john kerry said
the united states and china could reduce
all of their emissions
and it doesn't lower the temperature of
the world one
iota it's a scam but those are great
unions the police union not a good union
but they're a good union